car au carreau les nids à 8 ans il est
ce que l'on appelle un multi dys
dyslexie dyspraxie dyscalculie des
troubles d'apprentissage qui l'ont
pénalisé à l'école savoir à l'école
c'était difficile j'avais pas d'avis
j'arrivais pas à lire et la maîtresse
elle pouvait pas être partout
à côté de moi mais aujourd'hui les
choses ont changé
lenny est en ce2 grâce à son ordinateur
et un accompagnement adapté
le jeune garçon a fait d'énormes progrès
le tout ce qu'il a aujourd'hui c'est pas
sans effort de notre part de la part de
l'école de la part des des
professionnels qui s'occupent de lui
c'est pas évident d'avoir accès avait à
tous les soins faut pas oublier le coût
financier important
sap répercute sur sur une vie de famille
comme lenny près d'un enfant sur dix
souffre de troubles cognitifs sans
déficience intellectuelle
problème la pose du diagnostic est
souvent très longue en particulier dans
l'yonne
le gros problème nous sommes comme
beaucoup de professions médicales ou
paramédicales très demandé donc on
fonctionne sur listes d'attentes et ça
veut dire qu'effectivement certaines
familles d'enfants 10 sont un petit peu
en errance diagnostique pendant
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
dans certains cas si la prise en charge
des dix sept améliorer ces quinze
dernières années un travail
d'information auprès des enseignants et
accompagnants reste nécessaire
une détection précoce de ces troubles
permet d'améliorer le niveau scolaire de
l'enfant et l'insertion professionnelle
de la dure